we start with breaking news russian news
agencies are reporting that mikhail
gorbachev the former soviet leader who
helped bring the cold war to a peaceful
conclusion
has died he was 91 years old with
policies that promoted free speech and
reform within the communist bloc
gorbachev forged a new dialogue with the
west it was one that ultimately brought
down the iron curtain that had divided
europe since 1945.
his policies also helped put germany on
the path to reunification
[Applause]
mikhail gorbachev arrived and freedom
followed
when he visited east berlin for the
gdr's 40th anniversary celebrations
gorbachev urged erichonica to implement
reforms
he warned the east german leader saying
life punishes those who come too late
[Music]
a month after his visit the berlin wall
fell
and with it the iron curtain that had
divided europe for decades
[Music]
it was gorbachev's reformers policies
that helped unleash a peaceful
revolution across eastern europe
he laid out his agenda in his first
speech as leader of the soviet union
a stark contrast to what had gone before
the right to live in peace and freedom
is the most important basic right of
each individual
[Applause]
gorbachev wanted to change the soviet
union
to bring it closer to the people
he promoted glasnost openness and
perestroika reforms
two words that will forever be
associated with him
his new outlook was popular with many
his policies also applied to the
military despite the resistance of
soviet generals
i'm convinced that we will also have to
reform our military
we have far too many weapons
we have to seek dialogue with other
superpowers and reduce our arsenals to a
reasonable extent
[Applause]
as a result of that dialogue gorbachev
and u.s president reagan signed the
first of many disarmament treaties in
1987.
[Applause]
it was the beginning of the end of the
cold war
in 1990 gorbachev was awarded the nobel
peace prize for his key role in bringing
about a new peaceful world order
internationally he was highly regarded
but at home he was increasingly under
pressure
the economic situation was dire the
soviet union on the verge of falling
apart
communist hardliners staged a coup
against gorbachev in 1991 and put the
soviet leader under house arrest in his
holiday retreat in crimea
one man stopped them boris yeltsin the
russian president
[Applause]
gorbachev was allowed to return to
moscow
but politically he was ruined
yeltsin banned the communist party and
publicly humiliated gorbachev
shortly afterwards the soviet union was
dissolved
in december 1991 mikhail gorbachev
announced his resignation
his attempts to regain political ground
in the new russia failed
many russians held him responsible for
the demise of the soviet union but while
his own country turned its back on him
gorbachev was hailed around the world as
the man who helped tear down the iron
curtain
and bring about a peaceful
revolution we want to pull in our
correspondent roman goncharenko for more
roman we want to let our viewers know
you met mikhail gorbachev personally i
want to talk about that in just a moment
but first i just want to get your
reaction um like everyone around the
world we're just hearing about the
passing of mikhail gorbachev what did
you think when you heard the news
well um as many i've been expecting that
because there were reports that he was
very ill very sick and he is 92 years
old um when we heard that so um
he was an old man and um
it is no surprise but still it's it's um
this this news is is has struck me i
have to confess because uh he's such a
huge historical figure
um
historical figure not just for russia
but all the former soviet republics
including um ukraine where the war is
now going on
and um of course for the west for the
whole world so his legacy is extremely
important it is actually being destroyed
by president putin at this very moment
during this war in ukraine i've just
referred to
there when we talk about collective
memory of mikhail gorbachev there is the
memory that we have of him
here in the west
and there's also the memory that has
been pushed inside russia and i dare say
that those are two very different
notions about mikhail gorbachev aren't
they
of course but things change you know um
gorbachev was a hero for the soviet
people in the late 90s and early um
late 80s and early 90s
so he was the one who gave people
freedom who gave freedom of speech the
words glassnest and perestroika
meaning that change is coming possible
we can the soviet union or
later russia another republic could
leave in peace with the west that's that
was the key message he gave people the
right to travel actually
because the soviet union was a closed
empire so you couldn't just go abroad
before him
and uh millions of people are grateful
for that
um and uh
later in the 90s and and when putin came
to power in russia um the attitude
changed
most of most people disliked gorbachev
uh they blame him uh for the collapse of
the soviet union
um
they think that he was too soft with the
west that the west betrayed him
this is what most russians think today
for a minority in russia he's still a
hero
and
they are still very grateful to him
for for giving the russians and other
peoples of the former soviet union just
what i've just said freedom first of all
the right to travel freedom of speech um
democracy so um um i do hope
that maybe in 10 or 20 years we don't
know um how russia is developing
but i think that good and and um towards
gorbachev could change as well and come
back to the roots where it all started
he is a historic figure
and how can you imagine how
russia is going to
mark his passing i mean he was leader of
the soviet union
normally we would expect there to be
some type of state funeral for someone
like mikhail gorbachev is that something
that um you expect
in a russia that is being led by
vladimir putin
it is difficult to imagine a big
[Music]
state funeral because he is very much
disliked by by the majority of russians
but
you never know
there was
when his uh when when boris yeltsin the
successor of gorbachev was president of
russia and the first president of russia
died
there was kind of a state funeral but it
was not uh so so big and huge i would
say so we could expect something like
that uh now in this case uh we do not
know how russian propaganda will try to
use it but we have to remember this war
in ukraine i've mentioned at the
beginning of our conversation is
actually about dismantling what
gorbachev created it's about turning
back the clock
and trying to restore the soviet union
by force
something which uh or all expert experts
i've talked to and and uh people i've
talked to
are very happy didn't happen in the
early 90s when when the soviet union
collapsed
peacefully
and uh 30 years later we are relieving a
kind of that collapse with with a lot of
blood and dying and this is this is very
tragic actually actually
roman talk to me before we run out of
time talk to me about when you met
mikhail gorbachev
well he was
it was i was very lucky to meet him in
moscow in 2009 we were talking about
the
fall of the burning wall in germany and
why he didn't use force at that time
and i asked him
if he was
[Music]
pushed by maybe some military to use
force and he said no i was very popular
and um
people supported me not to use force in
eastern germany and i think this is also
something that germany will remember him
for for being for for for letting the
urinification happen for letting the
burning wall fall
and uh this is his historic achievement
and he will be remembered for that
dw correspondent roman goncharenko on
the passing of former soviet leader
mikhail gorbachev roman thank you